three out of ten parents 33
three out of ten three out of nine
parents are supporting their children
financially during the pandemic
31 say they think they're supporting
their children
more now than they did before covet
according to a new study of bank of
america while nearly one-third of
parents told bank of america
that they've been supporting their
children monetarily mainly
many also said they're willing to pay
for major expenses of live
life events 75 of current or future
parents who responded to the survey said
they'd be willing to pay
for the child's college education 74
said they'd be willing to pay for the
child's wedding
49 said they'd be willing to pay for
child cell phone bill
44 said they pay for their child's rent
these are stats
27 believe children will be financially
cut off
after they've secured their first job 27
so one in four parents says
i'm no longer going to support them but
the other one is support them pretty
intense by the way
on the standards how low it is according
to bank of america study
affluent respondents between the ages of
18 to 24 reportedly had in
investable assets that were between 50
to 150 000
to a million dollars while respondents
above the age of 25 had investable
assets between 100
000 to a million dollars the three money
topics that were most taught
to the respondents were bargain shopping
65 percent
saving money 64 writing checks or
balancing checkbooks
60 i'll read this last one here for
those of you guys that like stats like
some of us do
i'm sorry adam but some popular money
management skill parents said they
want to teach their children include
handling credit cards and credit card
debt 92
saving money for retirement and
investing 90 strategizing payments and
money habits when funds are low 89
and setting a budget 88 percent well
yeah i mean because
there's there's the other story that
these millennials are living paycheck to
paycheck making a hundred thousand
dollars
i mean hello that's insane that means
they can't budget yeah and they're
saying i'm making yeah the whole uh uh
sixty percent of millennials earning
over a hundred thousand dollars right
now
saying they're living paycheck to
paycheck a business insider story
yeah how many of them are crazy how many
of them have their parents paying their
rent on top of it all or their cell
phone bill
give me up let me let me ask you when
you when you when we were growing i'm
just curious you know like
you know yesterday i'm talking to we had
the greatest dinner last night with our
team we were at this uh stake uh
house place and we had a board meeting i
had everybody read the book blue ocean
strategy
this is my home office exec it's the
best executive team we've ever had
this is i had all my c-suite executives
in at all my directors and everybody was
required to read the book and give their
we went through the whole spot analysis
and then at the end you had to give blue
ocean how can we be a blue ocean and it
was
10 hours of purely ideation last time we
went to dinner
and we learned our controller uh uh
who is absolutely a ridiculous guy his
grandparents owned
gnc own gnc so one day his dad's about
to buy him a ram dodge ram
his dad was 50 when he was born very
interesting story and uh he used to be
the president
of uh steel u.s steel company in new
york
so he tells us that dad if you don't buy
me the brand new ram
i'm gonna join the marines he was 17
years old he threatens his dad
okay so his dad says okay son
no problem his dad goes to the marine
recruiting station
guess it's signed as a father because
he's there yeah
he says here you go son you're off to
the marines in a month go do your thing
never call me back because that tells
him that he was so pissed off at the kid
never call me
he goes to the marines chris goes to the
marines
he serves he crushes it comes back
him and his wife they meet in a m
university they both go to school to
become accountants they're both
both accountants they decide to eight
years ago he learns how to go and deal
with uh horses
so they own 40 horses they have like i
don't know how many cows they have
500 acres of land in texas and they make
a boatload of money so suspect
i just so you know i'm your director of
fine i'm your controller just for hobby
because my main money i make i make a
lot of money
doing what i do with horses but last
time my cio david hayes
he says just so you know this is the
picture i had this the car i had when i
was in college
19 years old i said what is it brand new
porsche 911.
oh i said david get out he says yeah i
said were you spoiled yeah i said you
being sarcastic
no i was spoiled i said your parents
bought you a porsche and
he says yeah they bought me a brand new
puzzle what the hell is going on here
right
so how was it for you growing up and
what did your parents
take care and handle financially for you
once you became an adult
18 years old what was yours what was you
i'm curious what did they help you with
financially at 18
after 18. after oh no i was cut off at
16.
seriously yeah what does cut off mean
explain cutting like they give me no
money whatsoever
so the my mom handed me down
and so i got a scholarship in high
school
after 10th grade so 10th 11 12 to go to
like the ritziest
private school in miami miami country
day there's country days all over the
country
i was a public school kid and i was
pretty good at sports i got a sports
scholarship all counting for this high
school
and i went there and imagine me pulling
up
in the rust-colored honda accord uh
a 1984 honda accord like the poorest kid
in school
yeah the color of rust my mom got in a
car accident that she gave me that car
and then
and then basically i had this car and uh
it basically was one of those cars where
the lights came
yeah and the lights kind of open up oh
that's good but one of the lights didn't
open so one was like it was connolly
kind of like that
one eye shut like tom cruise and um
that's what it what i would pull into
school in front with range rovers bmws
you know the the the the nicest school
in miami
16 did you have a job or no like how did
you make your money i would uh
outside were you slang i was not selling
drugs at that point
i was in college but um but i would uh
if yeah if you pull up that that was my
but basically i would entrepreneurial
umpire baseball i would do little side
hustles to make money
love to see yeah i was uh
yeah there's my car right there but i'll
tell you i'll tell you what this did do
i'll tell you what this is i know why
you cannot procreate so
my parents did not teach me about money
my parents didn't give me any money
um i had to you know learn the value of
a dollar
but imagine being this new kid in school
who shows up with this piece of car
to the richest school in miami and by
the time i leave
high school i'm the captain of the
football team i'm the captain of the
basketball team
i'm vote i'm voted uh most humorous i'm
voted most athletic
i basically said you can make fun of me
as much as you want
but i'll i'm willing to laugh with you
guys i'm gonna kick some ass on life no
matter exactly yeah for all the ladies
out there who have taken notes
write all that down adam's procreation
resumes very it's stout it's good
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye